[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález culminó en la
ciudad de montpellier la tradicional
cumbre francia áfrica un encuentro que
en esta oportunidad en particular tuvo
un formato diferente el habitual
encuentro entre presidentes fue
sustituido por un encuentro entre el
presidente francés emmanuel marco con
actores de la sociedad de los países
asistentes la mayoría de ellos por
supuesto de áfrica la agenda estuvo
centrada en juventud en la sociedad
civil también el cambio climático
movilidad y el mundo francófono también
la igualdad de género y el desarrollo
sostenible un nuevo impulso un nuevo
relanzamiento de las relaciones entre
francia y áfrica así es como lo han
calificado escuchemos al presidente
francés si la deuda que tenemos con el
continente africano es una deuda con un
continente que hoy en día está creciendo
de manera increíble que fascina a todo
el mundo a veces también asusta a otros
más del 70% de su población son jóvenes
hombres y mujeres de menos de 30 años y
eso es lo que queremos oír de la
juventud juventud africana hoy decirnos
que un país como francia que tiene esta
historia tan particular tiene sobre todo
una responsabilidad de un deber el de
responder a las aspiraciones y pedidos
de la juventud africana y es tener
proyectos que correspondan a sus
aspiraciones y a lo que la juventud nos
pide hacer porque viene de aquí
pero hagamos balance en qué estado están
las relaciones entre francia y áfrica
este nuevo formato que tan beneficioso
es que balance se puede hacer de la
presencia de francia en el norte de
áfrica en este momento han comenzado a
sanar ya esas heridas dolorosas que ha
dejado el pasado colonial la cumbre
áfrica francia es nuestro tema de debate
en francia 24 y para profundizar y
analizar este tema saludamos a silvia
pérez o ella es magíster en historia con
especialización en áfrica contemporánea
ya se encuentra en la república
argentina también está con nosotros el
doctor akunin y en som y moore él es
profesor invitado de la universidad
memorial university de florida además es
historiador de la diáspora africana se
conecta desde la ciudad de miami en el
sur de la florida y aquí en el estudio
de france 24 está con nosotros al médico
dv él es profesor asistente del
departamento de relaciones
internacionales de la pontificia
universidad javeriana en la ciudad de
bogotá la capital colombiana
ustedes también televidentes hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar las
preguntas y todos los comentarios que
ustedes deseen a través de nuestras
redes sociales estamos en facebook
también en instagram en twitter pueden
seguirnos france24
s sant y luego mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta del programa es numeral
el debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas comienzo
entonces con silvia en argentina
preguntándole por las conclusiones que
le dejaron esta cumbre las opiniones de
este encuentro y sobre todo de este
nuevo formato que ha generado todo tipo
de opiniones
bueno muy buenas noches muchas gracias
por la invitación es un placer estar
compartiendo este programa con ustedes
bueno en primer lugar me han quedado
muchas dudas y muy pocas certezas en
realidad tal como tú dijiste antes es un
nuevo formato
caracterizado por la falta de
mandatarios africanos y por el diálogo
directo con los jóvenes como
representantes de la sociedad civil pero
hay que ponerle digamos muy en evidencia
que llevemos el presidente francés
recibió duras recriminaciones por parte
de muchos de los jóvenes que estaban ahí
y eso hizo estas recriminaciones tienen
que ver con esta tensión que hay
últimamente en la relación en francia
áfrica que ha sido muy evidente en las
manifestaciones anti francesas que se
dieron en varios países de
áfrica en los últimos dos años sobre
todo aunque hay que también decir que
digamos las manifestaciones anti
francesas se han desparramado no a lo
largo de todo el proceso de
descolonización y de la formación de los
estados africanos pero han sido
distintas y mucho más fuertes los
últimos dos años no sólo la teoría y las
tendencias de charlas de senegal y demás
no entonces hay que ver hasta qué punto
se puede digamos este nuevo formato
puede ser aceptado por una sociedad
francesa y por los jóvenes franceses que
esperan creo otra cosa que el discurso
paternalista de macrón
doctor me moore en la ciudad de miami y
su opinión sobre las conclusiones de
este encuentro y las impresiones que le
da este nuevo formato este relanzamiento
como lo ha calificado parís de las
relaciones con áfrica
muchas gracias por administración
primero y desde la óptica africana
centrado digamos así es más de lo mismo
si los personas las personas que estamos
percibiendo los resultados desde la
historia
escuchamos cosas nuevas pero no
entendemos de la manera como siempre lo
hemos tenido que entenderlas es una
manera de seguir
con el saqueo o el uso de recursos
africanos con nuevos jugadores entonces
sinceramente y sencillamente lo que
estamos haciendo es planteando una nueva
relación
desde un nuevo grupo de personas que no
tengan ningún vínculo con la historia me
refiero a los mandatarios del continente
africano entonces es por eso que hubo
una conferencia ajena si con diferentes
actores se está en este momento lanzando
una gráfica pero de estilo africano
central entonces lo que dice francia no
concuerden con lo que dice los jóvenes
africanos dos mundos distintos
y aquí en el estudio de france 24
américa la primera pregunta para a
partir en punto de partida del debate su
opinión buenas noches santiago gracias
por la invitación yo creo que es
importante ver que al principio esta
cumbre debía tener lugar en 2020 y
finalmente por la pandemia no ha sido
posible tener esta esta cumbre y al
principio algunos jefes de estados
africanos debían participar pero ahora
con esta nueva cumbre en 2021 era un
poco más complejo porque en un mes va a
haber la cumbre de la francofonía y la
cumbre de la francofonía
reúne muchos jefes de estados africanos
con francia y con otros estados de otros
continentes entonces era difícil para él
elige organizar una otra cumbre con
jefes de estados de áfrica y entonces
hicieron de este obstáculo una chance
para poner en escena un diálogo entre
macro y la juventud africana lo que
permite amar como poner en escena una
idea de ruptura con la tradicional
política africana diferencia muy
centrada en los jefes de estados y eso
permite también no tener que invitar
jefes de estados controvertidos porque
hubo recientemente golpes de estados en
mali en guinea y marcó entonces no tenía
finalmente un interés en invitar estos
tipos de mandatarios tampoco un interés
en invitar por ejemplo un mandatario
como paul biyá que está en el poder en
camerún desde 1982 entonces hubo una una
cumbre por defecto pero también
finalmente una oportunidad desde el
punto de vista del presidente francés
pasó a preguntarle a silvia en la ciudad
de buenos aires
qué es lo que se busca romper ya que nos
han dado
américa toca puntos muy importantes en
cuanto al contexto político que está
viviendo áfrica en este momento que
pueden haber sido usados como
argumentos para hacerle modificaciones a
esta a esta cumbre pero qué es lo que
está buscando romper francia si está
logrando y entender lo que está
sucediendo en áfrica
bueno es difícil de desahogarnos yo creo
que es en realidad que es lo que quiere
romper áfrica
los jóvenes africanos los preservan muy
claramente ellos quieren romper con el
discurso colonial con las aptitudes
coloniales con que se trate a la región
francófona digamos cojo a las ex
colonias francesas como el pre carrey
que se utiliza el territorio con bases
militares que se condiciona y la ayuda
al desarrollo que se les abre como con
un distinto paternalista con un discurso
civilizatorio fueron muy claros en este
sentido se pidió expresamente
al presidente francés que deje de
intervenir para sostener dictadores para
colocar el gobierno para sacar gobiernos
no emery que nombraba a algunos
dictadores es verdad pero no se puede
obviar la responsabilidad francesa en
esos mismos estados muchas veces en la
perpetuación de mandatarios que
surgieron como un golpe de estado desde
áfrica con un golpe estado no desde
áfrica lo que se pide es terminar con
esa política francesa avanzar en
en terminar con esa moneda que es el
franco cf a que está unida al tesoro
francés y realmente dejar de lado a
todas las políticas anti coloniales el
discurso va creo no ya desde hoy la
cumbre de un condujo hacia adelante
parecía caminar en este sentido pero
inclusive en el fragmento que hemos
escuchado de macro mata antes de este
debate es claro que el presidente
francés sigue manteniendo un discurso
como de tutelaje les vamos a ayudar los
vamos a guiar no queremos estar con
ustedes pero no desde una posición de
igual igual sino como una posición desde
un colonizador y eso es lo que se busca
cambiar desde áfrica
desde francia se proponen cambios pero
que también desde el discurso de macrón
hacia otros estados como hemos visto
últimamente de argelia o inclusive en el
caso de malí parecieron que francia
sigue tratando de actuar como si fuera
una
metrópoli más diciéndole a los a los
estados africanos qué es lo que deben
hacer
en la ciudad de miami entones le
pregunto ahora el doctor en su memoria
sobre ese punto ese rompimiento yo lo
planteaba desde parís para empezar el
análisis pero silvia perdón lo ha puesto
desde el africano que es lo que quiere
romper áfrica entonces qué es lo que
quiere áfrica que se haga notar no
solamente en francia y en europa sino en
el resto del mundo para que empieza a
tener una relación de igual a igual y no
esta relación que ha venido teniendo a
lo largo de las décadas como un
continente que ha sido sometido a lo
largo de la historia ha sido saqueado a
lo largo de la historia y que tal parece
que no logra romper con ese pasado
colonial y con esas ataduras con parís
lo que quiere aplicar es un futuro
africano
punto
lo que se proponía por el lado de los
franceses en un futuro francés
utilizando leal áfrica para enriquecerse
y avanzarse a francia inclusive con
personas del áfrica en la francia
entonces si usted escucha a lo que se
está diciendo por diferentes países y
este es el punto que se ha de aclarar
aquí francia un país
áfrica un continente
ya entonces como así que debemos tener
servir o mirar al áfrica este la
francofonía si es lo que están diciendo
allá en el áfrica los jóvenes los
jóvenes quieren desarrollar su propio
futuro si no ser entre comillas
desarrollado
a favor de los demás entonces terminó
con este punto mira a lo que nos dice la
evidencia
dada por la historia
francia utilizaba la tecnología cultural
para desarrollar
para desarrollarse durante sus épocas
coloniales sí con la mano de obra
africana en las acciones de las plantas
plantaciones después durante el
colonialismo se siguió más pero se llegó
al mismo continente africano para llevar
a cabo la misma cuestión utilizar la
tecnología y la cultura africana para
enriquecerse y desarrollar a francia
ahora lo que quiere francia no es la
cuestión del cuerpo ni del oliveral sino
de la intelectualidad es entrenar
cerebral y lo que busca francia de los
africanos ahora entonces lo que queremos
como artista nos enlazadas por el
continente igual es un futuro africano
hecho por los africanos y hecho para los
africanos
aquí me lo escriben france24 opiniones
al respecto y ya pasamos a preguntarle
sobre otros temas américa sí no creo que
eficiente áfrica es un continente y en
cuanto a la oración francia áfrica creo
que es necesario ver la diversidad de
situación los intereses de francia no
son los mismos según las regiones el
pasado de francia no es el mismo con
todos los estados del continente hay
sobre todo en cuanto a la policía de
francia una dimensión militar que sigue
siendo muy importante con en particular
la operación bajan en el sahel con
actualmente cinco mil soldados
desplegados hay una relación con el
pasado que sigue fuerte y un
reconocimiento de una cierta manera de
la del lado internacional de la
importancia de la oración francia áfrica
pero a nivel económico la duración del
comercio con áfrica no es algo
fundamental en la economía francesa
viendo las respuestas y las opiniones de
los tres invitados podemos sacar aquí la
conclusión función of o no funcionó
entonces esta cumbre desde el punto de
vista de francia veamos lo primero desde
ese punto de vista funcionó logró el
cometido y las perspectivas se lograron
yo creo que no debemos olvidar que
estamos a seis meses de las elecciones
presidenciales y esto fue también un
acto político y un acto de campaña
electoral para macu para también su
oración con la diáspora y para marcar
una diferencia con la los futuros
candidatos de derecha y extrema derecha
desde este punto de vista tal vez ha
sido un poco beneficioso para mccomb
para su electorado para sus aspiraciones
electorales en cuanto a la oración
francia áfrica veremos en unos años pero
el problema es que sin la presencia de
los responsables políticos va a ser
difícil a fructiferar con él esta
reunión obama ya lo había dicho obama ya
había hecho también en este mismo tipo
de reuniones diáspora con la sociedad
civil no hubo grandes resultados en
cuanto a
la
desarrollo de la política africana de
eeuu y ya para verlo desde el áfrica nos
silvia el balance para pasar ahorita a
hablar de otros temas como el tema
militar y la presencia de militares
franceses en el sahel el gran balance
áfrica simplemente no fue escuchada
entonces en este en esta cumbre desde la
óptica que se esperaba desde áfrica
bueno desde el discurso nos da la
sensación de que marc matrona ha tomado
nota de algunas cuestiones que le han
propuesto a los jóvenes por ejemplo en
la crítica que le hicieron a la
intervención francesa libia donde él
dice que no debería haberse hecho porque
porque bueno porque se vulneró la
sociedad ni de un estado y demás
cuestiones no sociales el discurso
pareciera que algo se escuchó desde la
práctica suena poco porque en realidad
las propuestas de macro no como como
decía el profesor moore antes son como
más de lo mismo no vamos a relanzar una
nueva cooperación un nuevo fondo de
ayuda que va estar administrado por
gente independiente para no volver a
caer
en los los errores del pasado pero sigue
siendo más de lo mismo porque en
realidad la manera de que esto cambie es
posicionarse de otra forma frente a
áfrica no como que como bien decían
antes es un continente en un país
entonces posicionarse desde otro lugar
no posicionarse desde desde estar igual
a igual un presidente de los pedidos con
los presidentes de los diversos estados
africanos mientras se les ido hablando
desde arriba va a ser un poco difícil
tener algún resultado un poco más
complejo el completo de todas formas si
con este coincidió con américa esto fue
un acto electoral no entonces
probablemente macro no haya buscado otra
cosa no para los jóvenes africanos
fuerza ahora poco porque los grandes
temas que preocupaban a gran parte de
los jóvenes africanos no fueron tratados
en esta cumbre porque claramente son
temas que había que tratar con jefes de
estado desde el tema de la moneda de las
cuestiones comerciales algunas
cuestiones de encuesta culturales y toda
la cuestión militar
bueno le pasó a preguntarle entonces al
doctor moore cómo empezar entonces a que
los países africanos y los estados
africanos sean vistos de igual a igual
por los países europeos en este caso
francia
ese es el punto el dicho va si se cambia
de ropa no se cambia quién sos
cierto entonces hablar país por país con
la francia es bien el país está al
inicio me entendés entonces también a la
vez que usted está teniendo esas esos
diálogos y entender bilaterales se ha de
tener gente y apta para el cambio y de
ahí se ha de formar la nueva generación
de pensadores
intelectos intelectuales digo y
profesionales africanos entonces si la
idea para macro no era señalar o
identificar quiénes fueron los futuros
pensadores dan a francia ahí porque
saben con quién tratar en el futuro pero
si estamos hablando del desarrollo de
los diferentes países africanos ese es
un una discusión
a dentro de los países africanos y nada
tiene que ver con francia
otra cosa
qué significa tener relaciones con
europa en el siglo
20 o sea en el
2021 sí es decir que usted quiere que
francia quede como parte del futuro de
su país o es que no se puede quitar la
presencia de francia en su país entonces
para mí francia gana porque sigue siendo
siendo parte de la mente ocupa un
espacio en la mente de determinadas
personas el continente africano si vamos
a adelantarnos
sanamente como africanos
tenemos que hablar entre sí entre
nosotros dignos no con personas y
entidades como francia sí
sobre este punto aymerich que tanto es
esa relación de dependencia de estos
estados africanos con francia
partiendo del punto que explica el
doctor moore
que es momento para que áfrica se mire
desde adentro se aúna desde adentro
antes de empezar a tener una relación
como 11 con con francia que tanto hay de
esta dependencia cuando creo que hay dos
cosas primero hay la voluntad de tener
instituciones regionales de fortalecer
el panafricanismo existe la unión
africana existen varias comunidades
economías regionales pero a veces estas
organizaciones no funcionan muy bien
tienen dificultades es difícil construir
una unidad a nivel político a nivel
económico a nivel militar y por otro
lado a nivel de las curaciones
exteriores es importante destacar la
diversificación de las colecciones
exteriores de los estados africanos ya
no hay solamente una importancia de la
población áfrica europa china es el
primer socio comercial de el continente
africano desde 2009 hay una presencia
también de la india de japón de turquía
a los estados del golfo también tiene
una política ambiciosa en áfrica turquía
rusia lo vemos la competencia entre
rusia y francia en ciertos estados la
tensión en particular en mali cuando hay
unas palabras del primer ministro del
presidente
diciendo que van a tal vez acercarse con
wagner la compañía de mercenarios rusos
entonces ya donde vemos creer que la
situación es la misma que en los
primeros años después de las
independencias francia sigue teniendo
una influencia importante en áfrica en
ciertas zonas pero hubo una
diversificación y los estados africanos
pueden beneficiar aprovechar de esta
diversificación y para silvia nación de
buenos aires en argentina como deben de
ser entonces esas relaciones del 2021
del siglo 21 como lo estaba planteando
el doctor moore esas relaciones entre
los países africanos y francia
y toca un punto muy importante y es que
áfrica se ha diversificado y ya hay una
presencia muy grande de china de turquía
de los países del golfo y han
retrocedido un poco allí en la presencia
los estados europeos y eeuu
sí eso es una una realidad los de todos
africanos no son lo mismo que 60 años
atrás y la relaciones con francia
tampoco pero también hay que hay que
rescatar una unas cuestiones cada vez
que hay problemas es durante la 6
colonia francesa en las ex colonias
francesas hay una intromisión permanente
de francia desde el punto de vista
político desde el punto de vista militar
y muy inmiscuyéndose en los asuntos
internos del estado muchas veces con los
conciben connivencia no llega apoyo de
los mandatarios africanos y otras veces
no esto ha hecho que todos los
conflictos que se dieran en la zona del
percance francés se hayan resuelto de
una u otra forma con la intervención
francesa esto lo podemos ver el níscalo
como ver hinchas lo podemos ver mismo
mal y más allá de que el presidente de
mali
el 2011-2012 que pide la intervención
francesa en república centroafricana lo
hemos visto también en costa de marfil
entonces es verdad
que los estados africanos pueden elegir
no otros actores para gestionar sus
crisis pero cuando francia condiciona la
ayuda al desarrollo o los programas de
cooperación o la ayuda y el apoyo a los
gobernantes a que se hacen a la ciudad
militar francesa ahí las las opciones se
reducen que esto lo que pasa sobre todo
en áfrica occidental
es verdad que áfrica también ha
desarrollado sobre todo la unión
africana unidades regionales que cada
vez son más firmes y es verdad que no
siempre
pueden poder actuar con la solvencia
necesaria pero yo quiero decir solamente
una cosa la intervención de la unión
africana en el norte de mozambique ha
sido claramente exitosa a partir de las
tropas ruandesas y de la dirección de
sudáfrica
y sin embargo no ha sido así en
república centroafricana y quienes saben
bastante de estas cuestiones siempre en
señalan que el problema de la unión
en la republicación de africana es
precisamente el poder de decisión que
tiene que quiere tener francia que pasa
por encima de lobiano africana e
inclusive por encima de naciones unidas
entonces esta competencia este doble
comando en el tratamiento de un montón
de conflictos armados ha sido
absolutamente este perjudicial para
afectar en la gestión de los conflictos
es verdad que algunos otros conflictos
se han gestionado un poco mejor pero esa
competencia entre francia y los
organismos regionales ha sido nefasta
sino entrar en el caso particular de
ruanda que no pertenece digamos a
apretarle francés no entonces eso
también hay que hay que considerarlo
dentro del cambio de política de francia
hacia áfrica tiene que estar
necesariamente dejar de construirse en
los militarmente desde el punto de vista
de la presión política los asuntos
internos de los estados africanos doctor
su opinión al respecto sobre este este
comentario que hace es silvia del a
francia no en distribuirse en los temas
militares sino tratar de pasar por
encima de los organismos
africanos que están allí para actuar en
situaciones como por ejemplo la del
norte de mozambique que ya mencionaba
o sea absolutamente de acuerdo y es otra
cosa cuando la gente decía que se tiene
que acabar
francia a fritz ese programa eso no sólo
se trata de las cuestiones comerciales
y económicas esa es la realidad
juntos tenemos que iniciar nuestros
propios programas de desarrollo desde
los africanos entrada mediante la
panáfrica o ser panafricanismo y si
usted por ejemplo escucharía a
individuos como su excelencia americana
acción boricua
hay todo lo necesario para hacer lo que
se requiere en el continente africano
inclusive protegernos de entes y actores
de mala intencionalidad
entonces completamente de acuerdo
es obvio que francia sigue con la mano
ahí sentida si en muchos casos el caso
de maritza no puede ser más obvio
y si no solamente se utiliza el ejemplo
de mozambique pero si usted te serviría
por ejemplo el cambio de entre últimos
50 años por lo que se ha hecho la unión
africana se ha demostrado que sí se
puede por sí mismo el continente
africano dirigirse así su gran tour bien
doctor y sobre ese anuncio que hizo el
presidente de macrón
durante este encuentro de reducir esa
presencia militar en el sahel ya dijo
que no va a tener una larga permanencia
en mali se puede confiar y creer en ese
comentario del presidente
como ya se ha dicho
cuando vienen las elecciones dentro de
este mes
bien la gente dice lo que se necesita
decir allí para ganar la confianza de la
gente o el esfuerzo político necesario
para continuar
simplemente dicho
yo no lo creo no lo creo al verlo
no lo creo
y aquí en el estudio de france 24
también es simplemente un acto de
campaña un comentario de campaña o es
verdaderamente
tratar de hacer una especie de frente de
pared allí en áfrica para evitar que los
grupos yihadistas puedan saltar desde el
norte de áfrica hacia europa pues yo
creo que el marco ya anunció de manera
oficial la reducción del número de
efectivos franceses en el sahel hay
actualmente la misión barca no se va a
poner fin a esta misión pero el francia
va a mantener la mitad de los efectivos
por lo menos entonces dos mil dos mil
quinientos hombres y la dificultad es
que si miran el caso de mali el primer
ministro de malí criticó a francia por
esta decisión de salir de mariño
entonces hay esta dificultad de
permanecer o de salir y de exponerse a
dos tipos de críticas y yo creo que
pronunciar seguramente tiene la
intención de mantener un mínimo de
presencia tal vez no tanta presencia
porque no hay buenos resultados para su
embarcado hay más inseguridad hay más
diseminación de los grupos yihadistas
pero yo creo que el objetivo por el
momento es de mantener una fuerza
importante para impedir la
territorialización de estos grupos
yihadistas porque hay en esta región al
qaida en el magreb islámico y también el
estado islámico en granza da si vamos
llegando ya a la recta final del
programa quiero que comencemos a armar
las conclusiones de este rompecabezas de
las relaciones entre francia y áfrica
después de esta cumbre en la ciudad de
montpellier comienzo por silvia
preguntándole su conclusión que podemos
esperar para los próximos meses que
vamos a ver en esa relación va a haber
algún tipo de avance positivo o usted lo
ven simplemente como algo que va a ser
igual a lo que hemos visto a lo largo de
las últimas décadas
bueno en los próximos meses creo que
muchos cambios que van a ver porque
sobre todo para que para cambiar de raíz
las relaciones entre francia y áfrica se
necesitan cambios profundos a largo
plazo
y estos cambios profundos a largo plazo
incluyen muchas cosas en primer lugar
que el presidente pueda digamos armar un
frente político interno que sustente su
política y esta nueva visión de ver al
áfrica que me parece no soy especialista
en la política francesa pero me parece
que esto no lo tiene no por otro lado no
podemos esperar grandes cambios en los
próximos meses porque los grandes temas
no se han tratado
como como decíamos anteriormente por
otro lado porque para poder
realmente cambiar la relación entre
francia y áfrica habría que hacer
políticas a largo plazo no solamente en
áfrica
sobre todo en francia para que la
población francesa vea a los africanos
de otra forma sin discriminación sin
racismo no sin ver como que entran a su
territorio a quitarle todo lo que es de
ellos y eso lleva muchísimo tiempo creo
que no va a haber resultados en la
próxima américa que en el estudio
rápidamente de 50 segundos para la
conclusión no va a haber grandes cambios
hubo algunos anuncios de la creación de
una casa de los mundos africanos y de la
diáspora en francia la creación de un
fondo para la democracia en áfrica
algunos anuncios también de ayuda a las
empresas del sector digital o entonces
hubo algunas decisiones y vamos a seguir
a ver cómo aplicando estas decisiones
pero a nivel político militar vamos a
entrar en campaña electoral y entonces
los asuntos más tensos tienen que ver
con el saber la relación con mali y
también la los debates de memorias con
argelia y para el cierre el doctor sumar
su conclusión sobre lo que puede venir
próximamente
no nada viene de nuevo vale más de lo
mismo como se ha dicho al inicio francia
ya se realizó su propaganda frente el
mundo se ha pareciendo que deseaba lo
mejor para el áfrica y sus éxitos pero
absolutamente nada va a cambiar digo yo
no profundice bueno lo veremos en las
próximas semanas y los próximos meses
muchas gracias a los tres invitados por
haber compartido con nosotros sus puntos
de vista sus opiniones sobre este tema
de tira y afloja entre en francia y
áfrica y su relación histórica que los
une desde hace muchísimos años es todo
por el momento aquí en el debate de
france 24 sigan dejando todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales en nombre del equipo
de producción y de producción de
invitados les agradecemos la sintonía
[Música]